joining me today is a professor of
economics at George Mason University the
host of conversations with tyler podcast
and the author of stubborn attachments a
vision for a society of free prosperous
and responsible individuals Tyler Cowen
welcome to the Rubin report my pleasure
now I did your podcast once and I
believe that the first question you
asked me was do I like being on the
interviewing side or in the interview
side so I'm gonna start with the same
exact question I spent the first half of
my life being interviewed the last fifth
of my life being the interviewer for 58
segments and now I'm being interviewed
so for me so we come full circle and
then around halfway around together
there's less preparation when you're
being interviewed
yeah that's easier yeah all right so I'm
thrilled that you're here I wanted to
have you on for quite some time
you are sort of for so many of the
people that have influenced me you have
influenced them so I think there's a
there's a certain beauty this and we're
gonna do a lot on economics and and and
all sorts of stuff here but I always
like to start with sort of a little bit
of background just sort of where you're
from and history before we get into the
meat so tell me a little bit about Tyler
Cowen I was born in northern New Jersey
I was a nerd growing up I played chess
it was then economics and philosophy now
I teach at George Mason live in Virginia
travel a lot and I'm a kind of
information omnivore yeah and you're
you're a big basketball fan we just did
a whole basketball and being angry is a
big difference yes so me too I'm not a
huge college man or my it's not good
enough so why not watch the best right
there's enough of the NBA especially
with the internet in YouTube and it's a
way of thinking about talent evaluation
rules of the game technical innovations
conceptual breakthroughs how to get a
group of people to cooperate it's a kind
of economics in a way it's like a new
laboratory yeah so when did you get
interested in economics in economics I
was 13 and my father brought home like
some magazines and periodicals I started
reading them I then went to the public
library never stopped yeah yeah you went
to the library never stopped and were
you always interested in sort of more
Liberty
leaning economics or do you read
everything and then kind of figure out
where you Fowler I read everything but
early on I read Hayek I read Milton
Friedman some 'vine Rand Henry Hazlitt
that made a big impression on me yeah
and I was you know then 13/14 yeah was
that a weird thing for a thirteen or
fourteen you ought to be into or I guess
I think it was this was pre-internet
right so people were not exposed and I
just went crazy and I read all of
Plato's dialogues and I just thought I'm
gonna do this for the rest of my life
how can I find a way of always being
reading writing talking to people yeah
what do you like more doing the academic
side of things teaching or do you like
podcasting more public speaking I don't
think they're so different podcasting is
the new education right so think of it
as an educational innovation and you
reach more people the discussions are
often smarter than in the classic
classroom so I view it as one in the
same really kind of integration yeah so
okay so let's just talk about your
economic beliefs in general so basically
basically you're a libertarian right is
that small a libertarian what does that
mean because people say that all the
time let's I like defining terms
specifically when you say you're small-l
libertarian I believe in freer markets
social liberalism and I'm often
sceptical of foreign policy abroad that
said some libertarian simply refused to
admit that government can never do good
I don't think that's the case
anti-smoking campaign would be one good
example of something that did people a
lot of good it was led by government so
empirics come first look at the evidence
but I think overall right now people in
our society under a business and over
ate the government yeah so is there any
difference any meaningful difference
between a small L libertarian and a
classical liberal when people say
classical liberal I think it confuses
the listener there's the word liberal in
there what is classical mean it reminds
people of the 19th century I don't like
any of these words I feel I've written
and done so much online people can you
search and see what I think on any issue
if I'll still go with small a
libertarian I won't deny I'm a classical
liberal so I should probably be saying
small L libertarian by your definition I
agree it's gotten confusing I'm trying
to clean up the word liberal so so
deeply that it becomes hard to do that
because people have such just
associating with
word if I could just call myself liberal
as you can in some European countries
that would be my preferred approach yeah
but here it just won't work right that's
the problem yeah well this is listened
to all over the world so in English I'm
a liberal you're a liberal yes that's
nice so light touch a government how do
you figure out where the right spot for
government to do some things it's
because I'm sure there's libertarians
that maybe our vehicle libertarians that
are going all right well even if the
anti smoking thing worked it's not the
purview of government to do such things
I believe in the power of economic
growth the significance of just
compounding returns over time an economy
that grows at 3% over time becomes much
much wealthier than an economy growing
at 2% so we need to ask like what are
genuine public goods the government
should provide I think support for basic
science a basic social welfare state or
safety net obviously foreign policy then
there are particular instances where
governments have done good but the
presumption should be in favor of
Liberty people do have individual rights
you just can't take all their money from
them we way over regulate most of our
economy we could be far more dynamic
we've had wage stagnation in this
country for decades and we are
complacent about all that that's my
basic take on America today yeah and I
think you know I'm I'm pretty much on
board of all that are you shocked at the
amount of individual liberty that people
sort of want to outsource to the
government as you said they want to
trust government more than then markets
right now on social issues I'm fairly
heartened I don't think people should
ever go to jail for smoking pot say and
we're moving in that direction I never
expected that say 15 years ago gay
rights gay marriage again it wasn't
clear a while ago that would happen
that's great yeah in those areas people
have been very protective and fought
hard for good changes but when it comes
to economics I see too much resentment
and too much shrillness and just a
belief that most say billionaires out
there and somehow didn't earn their
wealth and it's our job to take it from
you which is becoming a huge theme right
now right I mean Elizabeth Warren just
in the last week she wants the
billionaire's tax and she's upset but
who's the guy that got the the yacht oh
I forget yeah
he got a yacht and she doesn't seem to
understand that a lot of people were
employed to build that yacht at all the
resources that went into that yacht but
she thinks she has a moral right that
seems to be coming out of the left a lot
these days Cortes is doing this that
there's a moral right to take people's
money who have too much I think a lot of
it is just competition for the voters so
everyone wants either the nomination or
more publicity so they put forward crazy
ideas to get traction on social media
the net result is to help Donald Trump
actually I call it the donald trump
reelection campaign the more democrats
talk about taxes it's ultimately a
winning issue for Republicans no matter
what Democrats say voters will never
trust them more on taxes
it's like health care no matter what
your view is when that's the topic
Democrats are more popular taxes it's
Republicans so it's this weird paradox
Democrats pursuing their own individual
interest in hurting their party do you
think that like when Elizabeth Warren or
one of these people that always want to
tax more and more and more do you think
they actually believe it's the right
thing to do or that they believe it's
cold calculating political move even
though your argument is that it doesn't
make sense politically like I don't
imagine them doing things that are
against what they believe will work
politically I think you're probably
right that it doesn't work but it's hard
to know if they they know that it
doesn't work it's a cold calculating
political move in my view they don't
quite think it's a disaster they just
think we need to move the debate in this
direction about taxing rich people more
talking about this for them will work in
that way so they have a broader notion
of work than what an academic might have
and more or less coincides with making a
stink about it now yeah does he drive
you crazy when politicians talk about
economics no I mean newer to that I'm
fairly detached as a personality type
yeah I don't like it but at the end of
the day if it drove me crazy I would be
less effective indicating myself so who
would you say in the political sense is
talking about economics in a way that is
roughly within a framework that you like
is there anybody it's hard to think so
I'm proud Gration but with limits that's
a pretty centrist position but the
center is pretty empty right now okay
but
lay it out for me and I'll see if we can
figure out somebody here the liberal
Republicans of an earlier time perhaps
so private immigration definitely Pro
free trade which is running against a
lot of the Republicans right now other
than say climate change issues I would
deregulate most of our economy I would
have much more freedom to build in San
Francisco or Manhattan I would have
radical reforms to K through 12
education with much greater choice just
a lot more experimentation I would never
send people to jail for doing drugs
unless they're selling drugs to minors
I'm not sure all drugs should be totally
legal but just kind of in a safe space
off to the side and I would welcome a
not so polarized America where there's
tolerance and a very strong Center and
some real belief about the importance of
America's role in the world but more
about building alliances than being
aggressive that mean that those are my
views yeah I mean I'm there on
everything you just say yeah and I do
think that empty Center that you just
referenced he's actually starting to get
filled up with people that have had it
with both sides which is I guess
heartening but we we've got our work cut
out yes yeah I don't know who the
candidate is really yeah that you know I
write for Bloomberg so I'm reluctant to
say Mike Bloomberg of the Democrats but
he is in fact my favorite with the
caveat that I write for Bloomberg's yeah
appreciate the caveat
otherwise the YouTube commenters would
have went bananas yeah if you don't want
to deal with their wrath wrath what do
you think about the just the two-party
duopoly that we have right now know how
hard it would be for say a more centrist
candidate like even now just in the last
couple days Howard Schultz of Starbucks
is saying he may jump in as an
independent and he it sounds like he'd
be a little bit more of a centrist
Democrat say than the the really far
left progressives but futile endeavor I
believe in working through the parties
yeah there's much about Donald Trump I
disagree with but he was effective
because he decided not doing the reform
party bid from the late 90s but he would
work through one of the two major
parties yeah so on most of the issues
that you talked about in terms of
regulation and
the economy and things like that you've
got to be pretty pleased with drunk on
regulation the administration has slowed
the pace but on carbon and environmental
issues I disagree with deregulation I
think we actually need to be tougher
yeah so even there that's a mixed record
Trump hasn't rolled back that much
regulation this is story to do but the
pace has been slowed I'm happy about
that yeah is there a way because our
system is so huge and our federal
government is so big is there really a
way to do a lot of this I think people
sort of hear the idea of let's rollback
regulation let's you know
drain the swamp all of these phrases
that that sound good but then they get
in office and they realize that this
this giant federal monster that is just
sucking money and employing all sorts of
people that probably it shouldn't and
all this but it just doesn't change it's
just the system is sort of corroded our
best bet is to invent new sectors more
quickly than they can be regulated so
let's say for instance the
virtual-reality were to really work and
people would take to it you could have
schools with in virtual reality
they would be unregulated not out of any
government tolerances just no laws set
up to really regulate virtual reality in
any direct way so parts of the tech
sector have had a light hand of
regulation not through anyone's wisdom
they just started doing things no one
had been expecting and so there's a kind
of race so do you believe so you
basically believe them that
self-regulation within certain
parameters does just happen it just sort
of happens itself I'm glad we let
Facebook and uber happen and that no one
had to ask permission do this company
sometimes make mistakes yes are they
perfect no are we better off having them
absolutely so if uber had had to ask
permission
imagine that oh like ten years from now
we'll do a pilot plan we're like maybe a
fifth of the drivers in Seattle do
ride-sharing in most cities say no and
they just did it I'm all for that right
and it always becomes a giant government
boondoggle anyway if you look at our New
York City taxis with you used to cost
about a million bucks just to get one of
those medallions and then it's like
there's no competition so I'm worried
ride-sharing will turn into that but
then there's always the new thing and
again it's this kind of race or
innovation
to outpace regulation the nice thing
about government regulators is they're a
bit slow right
the very formalistic it takes some time
right innovators can be very quick so is
that the silver lining more than
anything else that you think reliably
aren't that great right they're mostly
conscientious I mean they do the job
they're told to do there are countries
with much worse regulation than the
United States we should appreciate what
we have but that said if you look at say
occupational licensing for barbers or
beauticians or interior designers in my
opinion none of that should exist it
should all simply disappear tomorrow so
what would you say to the person who
would say well wait a minute what if I
go to get my hair cut and this person
hasn't been licensed by the state now
they stab me in the head with the
scissor
well murders against the law but I'm not
sure the licensing stops that the more
competition not just the license that's
stopping people from stabbing people
with scissors is that there should be
laws against teaser stabbing yeah in my
humble opinions yeah so okay so you
talked a little bit about the the tech
side of this why is it that it seems to
me that the people that I know that are
up in Silicon Valley and the tech world
in general is very very privately
libertarian these people want to
innovate they want competition they want
to do exactly what you're saying stay
ahead of the regulators and figure out
new ways to do all sorts of things but
outwardly these companies seem extremely
left and extremely controlling and
centralized
many tech companies are in California a
lot of highly educated California
employees are very left-wing those
employees pressure their companies also
a lot of tech companies have big
contracts with the government which puts
them in somewhat of an awkward position
and the ideal stance for many companies
tech or not is just not to be in
politics and I think most people in
business would rather compete as a
business or get a favor from the
government but the tech company is one
of the miraculous things about them is
defense contracting aside their core
model has been to supply better products
to users and not to curry favor with the
state and to me that's highly admirable
but are we entering an odd place where
they clearly do
have relationships with the government
at this point are we entering a phase
where and this is where this is the
great debate right now in my world as a
guy that's doing this on YouTube is have
these companies gotten so out of control
that there is now a threat actually to
the First Amendment because basically
there is government involvement related
to policing speech and are they
platforms or publishers that sort of
thing if I look at YouTube or if I look
at Twitter I think they have supported
far more freedom of speech than they
have hindered and if you even ask like
which set of views have been helped the
most by YouTube and Twitter
I suspect on average it's a mix of like
the right and some part of the radical
left but I don't think overall right
wing ideas and that's not even the
correct way to put it but I don't think
they've been harmed by these media quite
the contrary
yeah so I'm not as worked up about that
issue as some of my friends are yeah but
but either way you would even if you saw
more of a threat there you would there's
no is there any situation where you ever
believe the government should jump in
and do something any it's a tricky word
but I feel at current margins I would
rather the government not regulate tech
companies more yeah so just free them up
and just keep so you believe in human
ingenuity more than anything else I mean
I think that that seems to be the sure
enforce rule of law I think the notion
that a platform is not liable say for
everything that platform is used for as
we set out in law in the 1990s was a
fantastic idea it helped the internet
grow as quickly as it did that equity
capital could fund a new ventures
without being obsessed with liability
issues no one even knew at the time what
a smart thing that was to do so genius
of American government finally we did it
kind of unintentionally usually the good
things are done unintentionally I think
yeah but you know tech companies are
vulnerable so people think Facebook has
a lock and young people don't
necessarily want to be on Facebook and
there's always competition so myspace
was once considered you know untouchable
they would rule social media forever an
American history is littered with the
corpses of corporate giants that seemed
untouchable and basically went under so
if David can beat Goliath then Dave can
be Google yes yes all right I've got my
work cut out for me so I was on your
website this morning marginal revolution
which I first off I love the name but
the day I want to get the tagline
totally right here's small steps towards
a much better world I thought that
actually is pretty perfect for a way of
looking at the world that we need to fix
things
perhaps in the West with some small
steps with some marginal things on the
outside but it seems like there's a
movement right now where people just
want to rip up everything as if as if
nothing good has come out of the 200
plus years of freedom that we've had
here was that a little bit of why
absolutely came up with tagline in the
first place we need to start with where
we are
it's not about designing society from
scratch and the West has the best
heritage the best ideas most effective
religion that I think our world has seen
ever and we should embrace and cherish
those things and yes modify them when
appropriate but the American
Constitution is one of the great works
of genius of mankind yeah so how do we
then so what let's say you're Bloomberg
or somebody that's your guy let's say
well there's no one who's my but
somebody somebody who roughly holds
these ideas is in office tomorrow now I
know you don't want to give too much
power to the executive obviously because
you're into the Constitution and all
that well what does this look like well
I think the presidency of Trump shows
how little influence a president has
Trump is in most ways a weak president
most of his policy agenda has not
happened the courts have overruled him
our Congress won't act now the Democrats
control the house so for me the key is
for ideas in broader society to change
to try to be like a personal role model
for what you believe in and just to have
like your guy as president you're a
woman as president there's no such thing
and if I were very happy about an
election up I just wouldn't feel that
good about it I don't think it would
matter that much it's more about the
broad sweep of history yeah so then is
the key to that that we have to stop I
don't want people to become uninformed
obviously we need to be informed but
that the key might be stopped this sort
of endless obsession with politics right
now does that strike you it strikes me
as dangerous that we've turned politics
into the national past it's a bloodsport
now and it's the way you take people
down and
Sault people so this the simple rule of
how you would treat people to their face
or talk to them to their face that
politics should be done by all those
same URLs and just being genteel I get
that doesn't solve our national problems
but it stops some things from getting
worse and that's slipping away right now
yeah what can we do so you think it's
just just be nicer sort of at least well
different people have different roles
right so maybe some people it is their
role to be a kind of Paul Revere of
sorts but other people you know are role
models and they should conduct civil
intelligent conversations and that is
catching I see that on the Internet so
if you look at the best material on the
Internet how smart it is including a lot
of podcasts and YouTube shows compared
to what people like thought was possible
in the age of network television it's
just astonishing the intellectual level
so I see right now even sort of within
my crew love of intellectual dark web
people whatever this thing is that
there's sort of a split happening where
there's a certain amount of people that
think we have to the institutions are
changing say academia and the media and
New York Times every dose that they're
going through these massive changes and
we're watching all sorts of layoffs so
all over journalism right now and
there's a split where it's like some
people are just like let it burn it
deserves to burn it's time for it to
burn and then there's another version
that's like well if we don't prompt
these things up you know who the hell
knows what's gonna come on the other
side I would go back to this idea small
steps toward a much better world like
what can I do so I can write on the
internet I can have my podcast series
and I don't have some big mega plan for
what to do with the New York Times or
The Washington Post I'm genuinely not
sure those outlets will have to evolve
with competitive pressures in any case
I'm not like wishing for the death of
anything in particular and I think the
same set of people under different
circumstances can do a much better or
much worse job yeah so like I root for
institutions to succeed and not for
their death but again I focus on that
what's my comparative advantage what do
I see is missing at the margin and
really
hone in on that like a laser yeah I mean
I like that I think it's what I've tried
so what you're doing I think to build
here it's that I believe that usually
the things that I'm talking about here
are the right set of ideas and I don't
mind having you know difference of
opinion obviously with guests but trying
to keep it relatively civil and worse at
it on Twitter than I am in here and
hopefully people can start thinking for
themselves so what if I asked you like a
day you know what should we do with the
rotary club in Houston I mean you don't
know right not specifically yeah tell me
okay I don't know either
that's an interesting point what do you
what do you make of that that everyone
feels they have to have an opinion on
and everything yeah the second something
happens everyone knows everything about
the nuclear deal in Iran everyone knows
everything about what's going on in
North Korea and everyone knows
everything about you know tax margins
and everything else it's crazy actually
you know one of the themes in my book
stubborn attachments is on most issues
yes you should do what you think is best
but the chance that you are exactly
right it's actually pretty low yeah and
act and talk with that in mind so the
the first I want to get the first
sentence right the first sentence these
growth is good economic growth yeah
personal growth too but yeah well it
since you were talking about economics
but in a way you are talking about
personal growth sure when we talk about
growth so what is what does that mean
beyond okay you can say the the economy
grew an extra percent this year that
sort of thing like can you put that into
some sort of more layman's terms for the
average person that isn't particularly
interested in economics why growth is is
the important thing that led off your
book if you take a time period of like
about a hundred years and you had the
American economy grow one percentage
point lower over that time period we
would today have the national wealth of
Mexico not the United States so in any
given year a percentage point of growth
like maybe it's not that big a deal but
over time as it compounds it's the
difference between riches and poverty
the ability to have a job where you're
somewhat in control the ability to have
more scope for creative action in your
life then your certainty your children
will not die when they're very young to
take care of your parents better to have
access to the best medicines to be able
to travel the
world all of these things and people
want different things but wealthier
societies do a much better job at giving
us those things including sustaining
democracy so economic growth in my view
is centrally important why do you think
so many people believe that that has not
occurred here or something like people
don't want to accept I see this at
colleges all the time when I go to talk
to colleges and these kids think that
they're oppressed and that something
horrible is happening in the United
States right now and the only way that
I've been able to break through to them
I always ask the same question and I've
had nobody argue with me I save does
anyone in this room have it worse than
their grandparents and it has yet to
happen where someone raises their hand
yes and now I'm sure it has happened
where somebody's grandparents were super
wealthy and lost it but that would also
be an argument sort of against leftist
economics because it would show that you
can lose a lot of wealth which they
would want because they don't want
wealth to be accumulated but why do you
think this idea that somehow things
haven't gotten consistently so much
better which there is so much empirical
evidence of why do you think that hasn't
taken root say with younger people
some of it is myopia some of it of
course is that younger people have not
been on this earth for very long some of
it is we have taught too much a Galit
arianism some of it is I think our
society perhaps you can you explain what
you mean by that
a Galit arianism is the notion that if
one person has something and the other
doesn't that maybe that's automatically
wrong even if the other person is pretty
well-off or well-off by world historical
standards and I think that's very often
a harmful ideology I would do more to
teach like win-win plus economic growth
types of thinking that America is a more
secular society I think it just creates
a vacuum I'm not myself religious but I
think religion plays an important role
in giving us a framework and when that
framework is taken away a lot of ideas
enter the vacuum that can be harmful do
you see that happening right now
I do quickly yeah I definitely see that
and I say that as someone that's not
particularly really and especially on
the left which is less religious than
the right so is that what's happening
that they've sort of traded religious
thought or
an unmoved mover or some sort of
beginning of this whole thing they've
traded it in for a series of ideas that
are just about I mean it sounds cliche
but how they feel now not enough about a
higher purpose of some kind and one can
have a purely secular vision of that
higher purpose which is how I see myself
that religion is a very easy persuasive
way for many people to get there and we
are secularizing finally in this country
that's one of my greatest concerns is
that funny for you as a secular person
absolutely because I've never been
religious my parents we're not religious
but when I look at the actual data and
also religious people tend to have more
children I believe in you know a
populous America that is not like a tiny
country compared to India and China and
it's one reason why I would like to make
immigration work better and take in more
immigrants I think we should be a strong
country of five hundred million six
hundred million if China and India are
going to be over a billion so I had a
couple weeks ago I had Heather McDonald
in here who you're probably familiar
with she talks about being a secular
conservative now I know you're a small L
libertarian right if we're going with
labels but do you think there is room on
the right for a secular movement to grow
cuz I think that would be pretty
powerful and I see some seeds of it
actually happening right now
I know libertarians generally don't care
what your belief I tend to be secular
yes yeah I think there will have to be
right in a secular society so I think
there's right now more intellectual
ferment on the right it strikes me
especially on Twitter but not only how
much left wingers attack each other you
know people who support different
candidates this person's terrible this
one is evil Joe Biden did this I think
that's much worse on the left now than
on the right and it's partly because
they have fewer ideas to talk about and
I find to bring up an unusual idea you
will get further on the right currently
than on the left and that's actually a
positive sign so what do you make of
that positive sign because if you I mean
I think you know I know you know you
know a bit about my political evolution
I mean right would have asked me five
years ago that most of the people that I
agree with would be libertarians and
conservatives or at the very least even
though I'm still pro-choice and I know
some of them
thrilled with with gay marriage and I'm
against the death penalty and a whole
bunch of other things that these people
would be extremely opening open to
always sitting down with me and on the
other side there's there's almost
nothing left it's a reason to be
optimistic if you look say at the 1960s
70s people on the right I think we're
more open or maybe even more talented
than on the left and they were at that
time losing but you then have 80s and
90s were some of the classical liberal
ideas become much more powerful
communism Falls and then I think at some
point in the 90s there's actually a lot
more talent and openness on the left and
the right stultified well we beat
communism what do we do now well that's
when they went after video games right
yes well that was a big mistake the
Republican is attacking video game Akane
and they embrace too many politicians
who are intolerant or telling lies or
just being irresponsible and a lot of
the right is still in that rut but I
think if you look at intellectual
discourse it's better on the right that
may well again be a historical leading
indicator of change maybe not soon but
20 years from now I think they'll be a
payoff yeah well I think it's happening
I actually do think it's happening right
now but in ugly twisted painful ways
right it's never easy or pleasant yeah
do you sense we're sort of in the death
throes of something right now that
between the institutions kind of
wavering and with all the free speech
stuff on campus and just so much tension
you've mentioned social media a couple
of times that there's so many things
happening at once the way this is all
speeding up faster and faster and where
were you organizing discourse around the
Internet which is a good thing and will
be a very good thing but it's extremely
painful for many people I think that's
one of the big changes going on
I actually think America is depolarizing
I'm not saying that's a pleasant process
but if you go to someone in Congress
like what do you think about free trade
and you hear their opinion right now you
can't necessarily tell if they're a
Republican or a Democrat or someone who
wants to increase you know social
security government spending they could
be a Republican or a Democrat and that
wasn't the case and you know 2011 or
2013 so what people are calling
polarization is the stakes are higher
what is possible through politics is be
in greater and grander so there's more
hatred more mutual recrimination but
people are just all over the map in
terms of what they believe yeah well I
do think it's a rich ground for ideas
right now there but it's higher risk -
yeah yeah so we could it could spin out
of control
correct I guess podcasts always have a
lot of responsibility right now well we
all do in some sense of personal mission
in the old standard American Protestant
sense even if you're totally secular to
take that notion of a personal mission
upon yourself and go and do it to me
it's just critically important isn't
that it like to me that's it
it's your life grab it go with it demand
as much freedom as you can possibly
pilfer out of this world and take it and
yet that message right now for young
people unfortunately it's not catching
on the way it should or maybe it is to
your point and also understand we have
some origins as a Puritan nation I'm not
saying be a Puritan not at all but that
has given America a cultural strength
and ability to support people who do
this in terms of openness and resources
and the culture surrounding you how much
encouragement you will find how big an
audience you can build so early things
like blogging now podcasting just how
American those are we take for granted
but it's a deep fundamentally important
truth that Americans are sometimes
Canadians Jordan Peterson have been the
leaders in this area I don't think we
appreciate enough yeah is anyone else
doing it better is anyone else doing
basics of freedom and liberty and the
type of economics that you're talking
about is anyone doing it better better
it's a tricky word I think Australia and
Canada as countries are in pretty good
shape not with respect to political
Liberty but in many areas I'm a fan of
Singapore they have done economic policy
very very well and they have become
overall freer than they used to be you
know Western Europe in some ways has a
wonderful lifestyle but for me it's
somewhat deadening and not that
innovative but for cultivating like
quality of consumption and how to enjoy
leisure not really my thing in many ways
but they're definitely ahead of us and
we should
value that and learn something from it
what are what are some of the economic
ideas or principles that we're not
paying attention to you that we should
if you're you know like there's people
talking about ubi now there's people
talking about all this stuff with
automation I mean what should we be if
we're looking at the future now what are
things that we should be focusing on
learning about what I'm seeing is people
forgetting a lot of basics so ubi I find
a tempting idea but I don't favor it I
want can you steal man it for those that
don't know what ubi is universal basic
income the notion there's different
versions of the scheme but government
sends everyone money to support them as
a kind of social welfare so just like a
baseline everyone's got yes go from
there now I believe in some kind of
baseline so if you're disabled I believe
you should receive a significant
baseline if you need assistance I think
for the most part we should pay people
to work not pay them not to work so we
have the Earned Income Tax Credit if you
work and you're poor the government pays
you extra money I think that has worked
quite well it attracts a better quality
of immigrant when you pay people to work
rather than paying them not to work too
much of Western Europe pays people not
to work so the forms of aid we give they
are cultural symbols and they are potent
and the idea that it is automatic and
eternal that you just get cash it's
telling people the main thing of
importance in life is cash and you will
get it no matter what it's the wrong
message to send and is it it's stealing
the exact idea that you've been talking
about for the last half hour which is
sort of you've gotta innovate in life
it's stealing that idea from the
individual right we're just going to
give you something right if you don't do
anything you'll be able to sustain at
the bottom of the tower forever even
though obviously they're always gonna
want more and more for that right that's
alright it's gonna get you bi day one
and then it's gonna be like that three
years later correct but that said we
should find ways of helping the needy
I'm all for that yeah what's the right
way to do it I don't think it's ubi yeah
what else that people we should be
thinking about that's popping up right
now like when you're when you're in
economics conferences and things and
people are talking about what's going on
in the future which we need thinking
about I'm not sure how to fix climate
change I think it's a very important
issue
I very much favor nuclear power I hope
nuclear fuel endlessly one time so
climate change do you think this could
be I see a movement now it's coming from
the right actually yes
where there are people saying there are
ways to tackle this that could be done
through private enterprise and not
purely through the government now I know
you said you want some regulation that
is a place where you see the government
doing something related to the
environment right what do you see is
some sort of partnership there perhaps
you also need to free up energy
competition
so say you try to build wind turbines in
different parts of America homeowners
say not near my house right there's a
kind of NIMBY mentality that should be
much easier I know it doesn't always
look pretty you drive from LA to Palm
Springs you see all the wind turbines
but it is cheap clean green energy and
if you really think climate change is a
problem you should jump on board nuclear
energy in my opinion can be safe France
Sweden have done it just fine I'm
optimistic about the prospects for
nuclear fusion which can be safer yet
than nuclear fishing and this is a place
where you think the government should be
leading correct or leading is a tricky
area for nuclear power to operate
I do think nuclear plant operators need
a special kind of liability insurance
which we provided under the
price-anderson Act and that has a role
for government and I'm fine by that I
think it's much better than dealing with
all of the secondary costs of higher air
pollution so I don't think it can be
lays a fair but also you have to free up
the market so entrepreneurs can do this
right do you like like I've sat down
here with a couple and cat people that
really just wanted you know disassemble
the government altogether and enter
their Mad Max phase I really like the
idea intellectually like I like seeing
how far you can take an intellectual
argument how much government could
disappear do you like entertaining those
ideas just purely for just purely for
your mind if not for practicality it's
very important to entertain them or
learn something from them but again we
have to start from where we're at
there's a lot of things government does
that probably they're impossible to undo
even if they're unwise American well
that's why I was asking you yeah before
that we have this machine that is so big
that it's not
you should just come in and something
like Social Security you may not have
designed it from scratch the way we have
it but I'm not sure there's a way to
back out and undo it all because you're
caught in a cycle where people have been
promised payments right yeah so maybe
you know just live with that one and try
to fix some other things yeah I'm sort
of all over the place here but what do
you think about crypto relating to all
this and a changing economy I think
there's a 20% chance crypto will pay off
big time but not now maybe in 20 30
years from now just the way quantum
mechanics at the time seemed weird and
much later it became essential for
computers but right now it seems to me
the crypto revolution is failing what
was promised has not really come to us
I'm not upset that the price of Bitcoin
is low I see a lot of potential for the
notion of self executing market
contracts in a crypto system I just
don't see that right now consumers have
problems where they're clamoring for
this as the solution so I could see us
getting there right so in a bizarre way
if the problems of today exacerbate then
maybe that funnels this all to crypto
answers and also crypto may need more
infrastructure so you look at a possible
use of crypto well verifying individual
identities possibly crypto is much
better at that then you're with someone
on the phone and they say what are the
last four digits of your social right
that's a crazy system but for crypto
right we just we've just accepted that
we're giving it to all sorts of
strangers most likely Asia right every
time we pick up the phone yeah crazy but
it doesn't mean you can fix it quickly
just by having crypto now there's a
whole system built that way with
payments companies and government
bureaus and your personal data is
encoded with your social security number
your tax returns
even if crypto is the answer there it'll
be such an awkward
roundabout route just like for cars to
be a big deal well you needed roads you
needed service stations you needed spare
parts it took about 40 years for us to
put together like the network of cars to
revolutionize the world so I think a lot
of people are over promising crypto in
the short run and there is a very real
chance it just dies out and doesn't work
but I don't think it's all some fraud or
bubble there's real potential there we
don't yet know if it can work
the rest of the infrastructure is not in
place probably in the short run it will
fail but I still hold that hope I have
to say there's a certain pleasantness to
everything you're talking about because
you're sort of just telling people to
take a breath for a second right I mean
that sort of economically but personally
I was just kind of slowed down a little
bit for all of our problems the world as
a whole has never been in better shape
than it is today
2019 never ever so just keep that in
mind and you know gratitude is good for
your personal development like people
who keep gratitude journals it seems
they're happier they're more productive
my gratitude Journal I guess is my blog
in a funny way or podcasts but try to
have some version of a gratitude journal
in your life do you think as an
interviewer that that you actually do
learn every week I think one of the
things on most I have most gratitude for
is that I genuinely learn every week and
I forget that the average person doesn't
get to learn every week or maybe doesn't
take time to learn it yeah you could
learn every week but I mean I sit across
incredible people all the time and it's
like wow I learned something or at least
i sat with someone who knows something
that I don't know it's incredible I mean
you get that same opportunity we've had
many of the same guests not over the
years prepping for interviews is right
now the main way I learned but most
people now also have this chance to
learn every week podcasts other forms of
the internet cable TV is much better
than television used to be Netflix yeah
so there's a lot more access for
learning how do you decide how much prep
you're supposed to do because I find
sometimes occasionally I want to know a
little bit less because I find that it
will allow me to explore during the
interview more sometimes I need to know
a lot of very specific factual
information or chronological information
when when I did your show I was truly
impressed how deep you had dug into my
past then you asked me things that
nobody had ever asked me before I go
crazy over prepping so for Agnes Callard
I read Plato's symposium five times in a
row that's a lot of prep Emily Wilson
she just tree translated Homer's Odyssey
I'll have read that three times and she
did Senecas plays and she wrote a
biography of Seneca and wrote a book
over living and a book about the death
of Socrates and I'll read all of those
and reread some of the underlying texts
and her sister wrote a book on the
history of the fort which I've already
read and has some other books on food
I'm gonna read some of the books of this
whole book on the history of the four
and it's a wonderful book it's called
consider the fork Forks are important I
thought you meant maybe that's an
economic term no not good I mean the
fourth dinner table for literal Fork
Wow yeah so people's families of people
have you know a sibling or a spouse
who've done things I figure well of
course the person has thought about this
and they probably have interesting ideas
about it that are not out there anywhere
yeah so you'd rather talk about ideas
more than any absolutely yeah yeah like
the nitty-gritty of the day-to-day
that's when I see all these people
fighting over this policy that policy it
bores me to no end at this point it
doesn't seem it seemingly meaningless or
valueless it's overreacting to the most
recent signal in those ideas which are
you know eternal will be with us and
actually be more influential yeah so
that's a that's an interesting segue
actually to college campuses because
you're teaching economics first off has
economics at least from your position
been infected by a lot of what we're
seeing in the wider sense on college
campuses related to free speech shouting
down speakers because even if I find
this all the time if you know people
come up to me after events and they'll
say you know I want to tell my boss or
something that or my spouse time for low
taxes but if I say that they're gonna
say I'm racist I mean really crazy stuff
so as someone that takes the small-l
libertarian approach on this do you find
that some of these ideas are infecting
not so much economics is a much
healthier field it has a tradition as
being maybe more conservative isn't the
right word but more market-oriented a
lot of people disagree with me so
economists I think register is about 80%
democratic but they tend to be more
conservative Democrats and I don't find
that much just outright bias when I say
things I feel mostly accepted and indeed
even welcomed yeah now I know George
Mason obviously is a specific thing but
in general when I visit other campuses I
just spoke at University
Michigan to the philosophy department
but I spoke to them in bad economics I'm
going to use Chicago I don't expect any
trouble at all I don't think I'll say
anything incendiary either just like my
version of common sense right here's why
you should have a more positive view of
the world here's what we can do here are
the small steps toward a much better
world that we should embrace I think
it's gonna go fine sounds pretty hates
peachy to me well we'll see I suppose
well what would you say is the best way
to deal then with what's going on on
campuses even if you're not getting it
and maybe it's not happening directly in
economics departments right now I mean
we're seeing it leak into into biology
departments when we're talking about
gender and all sorts of other things
what do you think the best way to push
against this the the sort of corroding
of academic freedom if I look at my own
school George Mason we have a very good
record in this regard we have the
highest free speech rating from fire a
group you know about and our school I
think has about more immigrant students
or children of immigrants than any other
major university in America and their
attitude is so different they want to
get in education to learn something and
to make a good living and they're very
practically oriented a lot of them are
very curious and to them this is
political correctness is often a form of
nonsense and it seems to me a disease of
kind of rich white kids schools so I
think we need to be more cosmopolitan
and just less provincial America has a
long history of being provincial and
this is the new form of American
provincialism all right so let's back up
a little bit because you just mentioned
immigration but we started there but
yeah so lay out what a sensible
immigration plan actually looks like I
think that if you have a plausible
graduate degree from a real institution
including from most other nations you
should be able to get a green card here
I think we should have completely free
immigration from Canada I would say we
should have open borders with any
country that has a more generous welfare
state than we do because then those
people will not be coming for welfare
they'll be coming here to work and I get
you need to transition to that over time
and then I would still let in people
from poorer countries you need some of
what is called unskilled labor it's not
actually unskilled in fact but
the more skilled people you have they
need to work with people who can use the
burden of their time so you have working
women and they want nannies or that's
fine so I think we could increase both
skilled and unskilled immigration in
this country we've done a pretty good
job assimilating immigrants better than
anyone in the history of the world I
would argue absolutely so anyone that's
even close I mean I guess I guess Canada
perhaps er they do a good job
accepting immigrants but they assimilate
them much less so they have a tradition
like French you know Quebec is separate
and right maybe always will be separate
so they just let it be separate so if
you're a Sikh Chinese you move to Canada
maybe you'll stay separate it works well
it's very peaceful
mmm but they assimilate much less I
actually prefer a simulation but that's
okay so what do we do with what if they
always say it's 12 million people that
are here illegally right now how do we
how do we fix this then I would cut a
deal I think they should be able to stay
and if the restriction is no more wall
for that it's actually a deal I would do
I'm opposed to the wall but you know the
wall will not stop people most people
who come come by overstaying their visas
the net flow from Mexico has actually
been negative by a small amount for a
few years I think Central America is a
problem the notion that you can be safe
from Honduras and simply by virtue of
the fact that you made it to the border
claim refugee status because you know
there's a drug gang in your Pueblo I
think that's a bad system I do favor
some version of refugee status my wife
was a refugee from Soviet Union so I
appreciate this but just because you
know things are bad in my country I'm a
refugee because I'm close to the US and
I made it to the border I think it's a
very bad system it's very bad incentives
and it's overwhelming our court system
so some of what Trump says about that is
true again my goal is to find a way of
taking more of those people in an
orderly manner but to encourage just
rushing for the border I do think we
need to change that yeah well that's why
it really does seem we've imaginated
hell right now right you've got Trump
wanting okay he wants a wall and I don't
think a wall is a nice actually pretty
much agree with who he said I don't
think a wall is inherently racist it may
not actually work and maybe
there's all sorts of other ways to deal
with it but if the option that if the
other option that people see is that
you've got people screaming for open
borders then I don't blame all the
people that want the ball the wall and
we have a wall right now right and if
that's the way you the arguments gonna
be framed right so to enforce
immigration more properly but let in
many more people would be my preferred
solution so when you say cut a deal on
the people here so if let's say you're
throwing the Republicans the idea that
you're gonna get some more of a wall or
something what's the what's the deal on
the other side that what these people
the dreamers get to stay and we adjust
the quotas upward and say tech companies
can hire more skilled people on work
visas and we also redo NAFTA so
Canadians have the right to simply come
here you might want to limit their
ability to clean welfare I'm fine with
that yeah and over time think about with
what other countries can we have free
movement the European Union has does
this has done this within the European
Union I get that there's a political
backlash I'm not sure we should have
open borders with Bulgaria and Romania I
understand that probably doesn't work
but we've also got a you know a notion
sure but the the idea that 15 years from
now we could have open borders with
France and Germany to me we should be
working toward that I understand it's
not easy mm-hmm so I think when people
hear the phrase open borders they think
that means that you can automatically
come here and become a citizen but
that's not that's not what you'd be
calling for right well work rights but
we have a rapid path to citizenship
which I favor it's one of the things
that makes us good at assimilation and
you know both political parties at
different points in the past they always
go crazy like oh all these people are
going to come they're going to vote for
the other party I don't think we really
know 20 years from now what immigrants
are going to vote for or why so you know
Asian Americans will they remain as
heavily Democratic as they are right now
I don't know that that one's got to be
changing just the pure economics of it
same with Latinos I just say it's an
open question
so the partisan fear that like the they
who come will be on the other side I
think we just need to relax a bit on
that yeah are there any topics that you
shy away from
because I'm you have to keep on asking I
guess I can keep on asking because I've
got a whole I haven't even looked at
this but I've got a whole lot here about
economics okay but it seems very obvious
to me that through an economic lens of
looking at things the way you do that
you really could talk about anything but
also I interview people a lot as you do
and I'm used to talking about many
topics so what else is interesting to
you right now that maybe isn't purely
within an economic lens or even a
political lens whoa what sort of peaking
your interest these days besides sports
the question of how to find more talent
in the world so I think there's a
relative sir Fiat of capital relative to
talented laborers my view of the world
is if you have an incredibly talented
person who is good at execution that
person can get so much done the world as
a whole is under explored from this
point of view so you go to Nigeria
how many talented people are there well
they're about as talented as the United
States they just don't have the
opportunities look at how much talent
has come from India in the last 20 years
right China phenomenal amount and so
4050 years people like that didn't
really have a chance so how is it say
you were to go to Nigeria and try to
mobilize a Nigerian talent what should
you look for what should you do what
kind of cultural training is needed what
ought to change in Nigeria how can we
recruit that talent that's maybe the the
biggest question in the world today and
we're not good at it and we don't really
know what we're doing so I think what's
keeping the twinkle in your eye actually
is the fact that technology has led us
to be able to explore all these ideas
right now absolutely yeah and talk to
people about them yeah that's pretty
cool it is yeah I guess we are doing
something fun and these other countries
there except maybe North Korea but
they're connected to the Internet
yeah so you go to a random place in
Africa or I was just in rural Ecuador a
guy was driving me around and I asked
him do you listen to YouTube it's a
Quechua speaking fellow I asked him in
Spanish he's like of course I went to my
Ethiopian Travel Guide in Lalibela I
asked him do you listen to YouTube he's
like of course I say what do you listen
to
he said I'm a big fan of Armenian Church
history I
he can speak articulately about
movements in the Armenian Christian
Church in medieval times because that's
what he does on YouTube a guy in rural
Ethiopia that's phenomenal people don't
get how much of that is there what a
difference it's going to make people a
lot of peat outside Oh YouTube that's
like cat videos well yes there's those
two some are pretty good actually
but it's also medieval Armenian Church
history in in rural Ethiopia yeah like
how can you not be excited by that I
just the amount of people that are
thirsty for a little of this that's
right a little of it yeah pretty great
and they're basically all smarter than
the mainstream used to think and the
innovators who just talk to them and try
to be like as smart as they can be
they're attracting those audiences my
goodness that's exciting
yeah I don't how to end an interview
better than that a little excitement
that's pretty good it is you feel good
about it I do how do I do as an
interviewer wonderful you did fine as a
guest thank you very much for more on
Tyler check out his website marginal
revolution com
[Music]